[Music]
um hello from 30 to Adele celebrated her
32nd birthday on Tuesday with an
Instagram post that left fans totally
shook yep that's the 15 time Grammy
winner looking gorgeous and happy as
always in a little black dress the
birthday girl hit up the caption to
think her friends and fans for their
well wishes on her special day quotes
thank you for the birthday love I hope
you're all staying safe and sane during
this crazy time
Adele also took a beat to thank all of
the first responders and essential
workers who are keeping us safe while
risking their lives amid the corona
virus pandemic adding you are truly are
angels
Adele's friend Aaron Paul's wife Lauren
Paul also posted some birthday love for
the singer on her instace Tori sharing
this snuggled up pic with the text
you're such a good friend then there was
this spear shot
that's Adele in a sexy black mini dress
tights and knee-high boots next to
Lauren her hubby Erin and Nicole Richey
Lauren called the British pop star and
angel babe adding you glow because your
heart is full I'm so proud of the human
you are it was just
fans first started noticing Adele's
physical transformation after the
famously private star shared this pic of
herself at Drake's birthday bash in
October then in December she posted some
sultry Christmas snapshots and in
February she showed off her new look at
jay-z and Beyonce's Oscars after-party
back in March 2016
Adele opened up to Vogue magazine about
living a healthier lifestyle revealing
that she had given up alcohol and
cigarettes this is weed and special she
explained quote I was trying to get some
stamina for my tour so I lost a bit of
weight
now I fit into normal off-the-shelf
clothes and Adele was hitting the gym
that same year Adele shared a few pics
of her working out and well it's a damn
mood
yes that's Adele faking tears while she
pumps some iron same girl same of course
fans are eagerly awaiting new music from
Adele who said back in February while
performing at her BFFs wedding that we
could expect her new album in September
last year Nicki Minaj got her hopes up
for a hot SEC that an epic collab
between the two powerhouses could be in
the works
Nomi you don't often talk about the
collaborations but is there an Adele
Nicki something could be in the works
would you do it if she asked
yes and yes yes yes
Adele made me swear to secrecy that I'm
not allowed to tell anyone that I'm
working with her and we already shot a
video and it's an epic song Nikki later
tweeted that she was just being
sarcastic
but it would make sense Adele is a huge
fan of the rapper she even spit Nikki's
rhymes during an epic installment of
carpool karaoke in 2016
[Music]